today we are going to see two games and
I think you will enjoy them because
those games are very very inspiring the
idea of this games is a little bit in
continuation to what we did the previous
week and it has to do with taking
advantage of better development and the
initiative the initiative is when we are
calling the shots
it's we have the right to move we have a
push in the position we have a chance to
create another threat and another threat
and try to get our opponent into trouble
and well it works in those two games
let's take a look at the first game in
the first game you see that black is
accepting a gambit again because when
you sacrifice a little bit of material
and the price that you charges the
opponent is a few Tempe a few moves is
gaining in time when his opponent gets a
little greedy as you will see he gets
punished so we have a normal key for
opening Sicilian defense Knight of 3:1
to d6 and in this position we know that
there are many moves that are possible
d4 is the main line striking at the
center pawn takes Knight takes Knight f6
and white is trying to play a little bit
of a side line normally the move Knight
c3 comes like automatically the knight
was attacking the pawn our Knight is
defending the pawn that's very very
normal so instead he plays the move
Bishop to b5 check okay so let's think
about this move for a moment what is
that what is going on of course there's
no time to take the pawn the bishop is
checking the King the knight cannot come
to his natural square on c6 because then
I will just take pawn takes Bishop takes
winning upon and then I'm going to win a
rock in the corner so black has to make
a choice between Bishop d7 or ninety
seven some people like to keep our
Bishop for later they think hey the
bishop on b5 is going to be vulnerable
maybe we can attack it later play like a
six and then move our be pawn but
can also play Bishop d7 97 is our topic
okay now I played the move castles of
course he could play the move Knight c3
just defend upon in a normal way but he
says to his opponent listen free pawn
for you take it take my pawn I dare you
to take it at first black thought about
it and say hmm his King is already
cancelled my king is stuck in the center
both sides have to develop pieces if I
take the spawn and he is going to go
rook e1 or something what will happen to
me let's check it out he didn't dare do
it let's see why because after takes
here Knight f6 Knight f5 comes and this
is a monster position for white monsters
position I'm threatening to play Knight
x d6 checkmate and even if you defend it
with your queen I'll still take it
because my queen is behind
notice how this rook is pinning this
pawn all the way here bad news so black
has to give the pawn at a minimum he has
to play a six then my knight will just
stay here and you'll have to give me
your good Bishop my queen will take what
can I say this position is just
wonderful for white I get my material
back I have big development advantage I
have two bishops because I will win the
bishop on f8 for my knight happy happy
happy so ok he decides let me not take
this pawn let me play the move g6 and
develop my bishop ok very well so now
black is more ready he's ready to play
Bishop g7 and Castle in two moves white
plays the move c4 again a very very
interesting move the idea of this movies
has two different themes one he is still
challenging the opponent to take the
pawn very tempting look like a free pawn
in the center and you see what black did
the other thing is I want to play now
Knight to c3 and defend my stuff but I
really like the fact that I have two
pawns on e4 and c4 because they make a
very strong hole in the center they make
the move d5 or later on b5 very hard to
execute so we call this a Marazzi bind
Marazzi was a hungarian player a
grandmaster and he had this idea of
playing
this kind of abundance that compelled
the Ipoh and the c-pawn to hold against
any breaks by black so black decided I'm
going to take you upon well maybe
instead the variation should have been
like Bishop here Knight to c3 castles
and then white would play well either
Bishop g5 or Bishop takes the knight on
d7 let's for example see this bishop
here a six takes takes Queen d2 this
would just be a normal game material is
even and black is not too bad I mean
he's kind of okay white he's probably
going to bring his rooks to the center
black he's probably get his Queen out
and get his robes it would just be
another game however in our game after
c4 he decides that he can no longer
resist upon he is very hungry for the
point he needed a snack and that one was
his afternoon snack now you will see
that sometimes snakes are not so good
for you look what happened now now it's
where the game really begins up to here
both sides were developing kind of
normally we said a black should've
played Bishop g7 just ignore that pawn
but it couldn't resist it and he took it
so now why it starts first move is
rookie the first move is rook e1 very
easy to understand what is the idea of
this move I'm attacking the knight
getting my rook on a very dangerous open
file right and now the knight better go
back I don't think that black wants to
play a move like f5 and defend the night
especially when my knight can come and
visit on this beautiful square guys if
you keep playing games I'll have to
separate you so decide now either you
separate or you behave so he decides to
play Knight back to f6 now we see that
there's a slight difference before there
was a pawn back on g7 and this one was
back on CJ and I could have just played
nine f5 like I told you now I can all
longer play it because this is here but
all right white is just saying I'm not
hungry to take my pawn back I just want
to show that I have so much play so much
more space and development for my pawn
that it's going to pay off later on for
now we can see that white has two minor
pieces developed one of them in the
center black
as one night developed you which is kind
of pinned and the other night that move
already several times here on f6 and
it's white to move look how much space
white has and how much space black has
in previous lecture I've mentioned it I
don't know if you guys remember or not
how do we count for space we pretend
that we put an imaginary line right down
the middle between the fourth and the
fifth ranks and we start counting points
every one of our pieces that reaches
beyond that mark or out there is going
to get one point so for example we have
a bishop that is beyond the halfway mark
that's one point it's attacking here
that's two three four the knight hits
five six seven eight with the pawn nine
with the Queen ten eleven twelve with
the rook thirteen fourteen with the
bishop how about black he has one two is
that good news that's not good news but
he has an extra pawn he says okay if you
don't do anything now if you don't do
anything that scares me I'm going to go
Bishop g7 I'm going to castle and then
good luck looking for your pawn I'm
going to be up upon completing my
development with no problems so white is
to be a little ambitious here okay he
decides to play the move Bishop f4 I
have to show you I have to tell you that
when I was preparing this game for this
class I was also looking at it with the
analysis energy with a computer and that
computer played a move that I didn't
think about and I'm going to discuss it
with you a little bit maybe even a
better move that when played in the game
just to show you how dangerous it was to
take that pawn the computer says why it
should play 96 when I saw this move I
had to really give a double-take I have
to twice look really because this looks
like but I don't even get the point but
when you take a close look boy do you
get the point
so Queen c7 thinking that the knight is
out of the question if you take the
knight I'm going to go Bishop takes
attack The Rock if you move the rook
I'm going to go Queen takes here what a
monster is position not only is this
pawn pinned but because this knight is
pinned I want to take your rook
it's not protected and if you even dream
about protecting your car moving it I'm
going to take this night because guess
what both this pawn and this night are
pinned so if you try to play let's say
this move I'm going to say thank you
whoops not just thank you I'm going to
say thank you what a disaster for block
complete disaster okay so you can't take
the night but what if you just ignore it
what if after this you just sorry what
if after this you just play here well
look at what White has here again he has
so much initiative he has so much attack
and so many beautiful squares he can
afford to give everything watch the
sacrifices I already gave up a pawn and
watch what I'm going to do now BAM 90 x
e7 well you better take it if you don't
take it to the bishop my knight is going
to move somewhere like the d5 and I'm
going to win the house so you got to
take and then Bishop g5 developing the
bishop for free now I just want to take
the knight on f6 thank you very much
because it's pin twice it looks like
it's defended twice but it isn't the
bishop is pinned to the rope and the
knight is pinned for the [ __ ] to the
bishop so after this you have to move
your king and now another brave move by
white rook takes a seven this is just a
crazy game where you can give so much
material you're going to be down the
rook but man the black king is going to
not find any relief so here Knight c3
threatening a very big check on d5
forking the king in the Queen once again
notice the pin here everything is pinned
he is stuck and if you try to run away
let's say my King f8 I will play Bishop
takes d7 now the knight on f6 is is not
protected so let's say you protect it by
recapturing Knight d5 attacking the
Queen the poor Queen has to go somewhere
let's pretend here check now where are
you going to go if you go to g8 97 is
mate just checkmate so you have to go
this way then we go Queen to g4 what a
nice little move
again I don't expect it to see all this
in your own games but just to appreciate
how when all the development is out like
when you have to Brooks in the corners
doing nothing okay then it doesn't mean
you're up the rook it's almost like you
down a rock because you have no
defensive pieces whatsoever and then the
rest of my pieces can just cause lots of
trouble now you have basically no
defense against me coming on the dark
squares you are really missing your da
square Bishop so let's say for example
95 attacking the Queen 2 times Queen g5
how are you going to fit how you going
to defend against the checkmate on e7
which of your pieces can even defend
there's only one move Arjun you
understand they only move but then
surprise Knight f6 check and what
happens to the Queen
that's right bye-bye is the correct term
so wow this is really really scary 96
imagine if you would have played 96 this
game would have been a real brilliancy
it looks like a funny move what happened
if you take it you can if you don't take
you're still stuck ok white played and
another good move Bishop f4 also a very
fun move he is threatened to take the
pawn on d6 everybody can see that so
there's no time to develop the bishop if
you just develop the bishop I'm going to
take this pawn not only getting my pawn
back but I'm all over the e7 pawn black
and just say bye-bye again so he has
several choices and what let's analyze
some of them in the game he went a 6
that was a bad move he has no time to
spend by attacking my bishop because I'm
not going to move it instead it should
have played a six or a five let's take a
look at the lines so let's say for
example is a five-night c3 the best move
again the pawn is pinned so even though
you fork my pieces you can't do anything
Bishop g7 and now I have two choices I
can take the knight on d7 or I can just
simply play Bishop here Knight here and
the pot on e6 is going to fall very bad
pond you see the arrow just shows that
the Queen eventually is going to win the
pawn on c7 and black is going to have a
crown position but black should have you
had to have done
he had to have tried that excuse me
because when he didn't watch what
happened he played a six now he is in
real trouble white simply said I'm not
going to bother move the bishop I can
give you a piece because watch what
happens
Bishop takes pawn d6 a sacrifice of a
piece now I don't like it when you just
give away pieces in your games like it's
Christmas because sometimes you just
give them away and there's no follow-up
please close the door
thank you but in this position with the
king stuck in the center I really want
you to pay close attention how would you
know when you can afford to sacrifice a
piece how would do you know here it is
the king is stuck in the center with no
moves you have four pieces that have
them left yet a fifth one if we include
your queen
this Knight is pinned this Knight is
kind of helpless and my king on g1 is
not even a part of the game he's just
resting there you can't touch me you can
check me the difference between the two
kings just tells the story even if I end
up losing my bishop I'm going to have so
many other pieces to attack with that
you have no hope so he decided to take
well maybe you shouldn't have taken the
bishop but what else I already get my
pawn back and you can't move the bishop
from f8 miserable really really
miserable he decides to say okay if I
have to suffer let me at least try to
win a piece but it's not going to work
takes 90s boy am i threatening some
annoying stuff now I want to play Bishop
c7 trapping the Queen and I want to play
97 check also forcing you to give me
your queen terrible really what'd you do
so he tried to get the Queen out by
playing Queen to b6 now Bishop c7 it
looks like the Queen is going to run
away but it's not so simple so some of
you might say hey what happened if I go
Knight check King d8 Knight takes rook
well then the Queen is going to attack
the knight this way or this way and both
the knight and the bishop are attacked
don't forget you already lost a piece
you gave up a piece on b5 so why it says
you know what I don't even want
j-rok and again I want you to learn
something from this game what is it when
you have a good move stop for a moment
and see if you're ever yet better one in
this position the rook looks really
juicy but why take a look when you can
win even more watch what he did
Bishop to c7 what a fun move to make not
only is he attacking the Queen with a
tempo but if the Queen goes too far away
Knight d6 is going to be checkmate what
to do now 96 is coming regardless if I
get to play 96 you're going to have to
second Queen for a night so he said okay
okay damage control I know that I lost
I'm going to lose something but I
overall ready up a piece let me give up
my rook for a queen my queen for a rock
excuse me and maybe I can still fight on
and he played the move Queen to e6 what
a sad move to have to make he has to say
okay here take my queen take it I have
to unpin the e pawn the idea is that now
if Knight d6 the pawn just takes it and
you just lost a knight for no reason so
of course white can be really annoying
and just move this bishop away saying
I'm not even going to bother to take you
Queen I'm going to threaten ninety seven
check but he figured out you know let's
be practical rook takes Queen pawn takes
Bishop back to F for threatening Knight
c7 check King f7 moving the Queen away
in the King away and after 97 he said
you know what enough you're attacking my
rook I don't have many good squares with
the girl with the rock when I move my
rook Queen e2 is going to come and the
pawn on e6 is probably going to fall the
position is just very very miserable and
he decided enough is enough in II resign
now in your games I don't want you to
resign I want me to play all the way to
mate
make your opponent prove that they can
beat you but when you play the
Grandmaster level they respect each
other they know that there's no chance
that while she's going to have an
accident in this position and he gave up
although I have to tell you there's a
tournament going on in Holland right now
and one guy was up a queen up a queen
for two pieces
and yet he made a draw couldn't win he
found it very difficult to win and this
is top of the line grand national
because his King was in a little bit of
trouble could never get it out
so did we understand this game great now
game number two and let's take a look at
what's happening in this game again a
great example of somebody playing very
powerful Chelsea the player with the
white pieces I've talked about it
several times this week and then the
previous week somehow it's really
coincidental because I was really
searching his games just looking at
material and he was one of the best
players in the world his opponent is
also a really well known opponent watch
what happened
watch what why does to block here efore
c59 f3 Knight f6 a very strange sight
variation normally black plays moves
like e6000 six sometimes even g6 but
this move is really not that common
mainly because white can immediately
chase the night and when the night comes
to the center where else is not going to
go backwards then he is challenging him
with this Knight he is hoping that after
Knight takes Knight pawn takes the Queen
is ready to come out the other Bishop is
ready to come out this Bishop is ready
to come out white enjoys a lot more
space for his double pawns so e six
again inviting him to take so he has two
pawns in the center and he does why
because he doubles the pawns takes d4
now black has to be really really
careful he can't just take on d4 with no
reason because he is going to end up
with two isolated double bonds and
whichever white piece is going to be on
d4 is going to be sitting there forever
you will never have pawns on the nearby
files to kick it out so the most common
move here I can tell you is knight c6
developing he decides to play the move
d6 it's also possible but it's a little
bit risky why because white is going to
move forward much faster and the black
King has to be careful not to get stuck
in the center watch what happened in
this game so in this position he plays
Bishop g5
Vella ping with a tempo I'm attacking
the Queen and very very risky position
because now the Queen is to move if you
try to let's say block with your bishop
I will take it then I will take here and
the pawn on d5 notice how its marked
with a green square I'm going to get for
free pawn freebie
not good so he said okay
I'll move my queen I'll be patient we
have a question say one more time well
it depends in the game he decided to
play Queen a5 so yeah I mean other moves
would have been Queen b6 maybe but I
think the 385 trying to gain a tempo is
more important so he gave a check and of
course white blocked in that simplest
way that he can and now he decides to
take the pawn on d4 okay I think that
this is a very sensible move what is the
idea if you take with the night I'm
going to play pawn takes pawn winning
upon and taking attacking your knight
if you take with a queen I'm going to
play knight c6 again with a gain of
temper with a gain of time attacking
this and this so why it says hmm
let's take a look at this position I'm
very developed I have two minor pieces
out my bishop on g5 my knight on f3 I
also have a very strong pawn on e5 very
strong pawn but I cannot be a castle I
have a bishop on f1 if not from a bishop
on f1 I could castle so he thought me
yes I just lost a pawn and he can take
even another pawn maybe even another
point it can take a lot of pawns but I
think it's worth it I think it's a good
deal for me
because all my pieces are going to be
very active and he is just going to keep
taking horns look how many pieces he has
back on the first rank one two three the
King for five so he decided to play
Bishop d3 sometimes it's really smart to
let your opponent take your stuff
because look at the freebies already he
develops a bishop for free then he's
going to cancel you can't stop me from
counseling so he decides to take another
pawn so far it's okay I think that this
is a reasonable move and do you think
why took
nope simply canceled he just says hey
you can have all my pawns for every one
you take I get another free move towards
the attack now it was really high time
for black to stop and think because dude
all your pieces are back home look at
mine I have all my minor pieces all the
three minor pieces active on pretty good
squares
I am Castle my king is safe what about
yours is like in the middle of a draft
it's a big wind flowing and guess what
your King is right there and my rook is
about to come to the a/v file when that
happens your King is really going to be
scratching his head where he's going to
go so this was a high time to start
defending he needed to play the move
this was very dangerous he needed to
play the move Bishop to e6 still white
would have some initiative here I can
just get my phone back here and it's
very risky to take because my rook is
going to come to the file and then it'll
be a game white will have a little bit
down in material but he has a lot of
activity but taking here was just too
much that is almost a rude move that's
come on
how many pawns are you going to take and
not take care of your King so white said
okay rook b1 so let's take account of
the material White has five points how
many does black have all of his pawns he
has eight White is now down three pawns
but it's not as simple as that all my
pieces are developed my King is canceled
when I take this pawn I'm causing some
trouble on this file as well black is in
trouble taking the pawn on b2 was a real
bad deal so he decides to play the move
D takes e5 let's take a look at another
possibility let's say he would have
developed his knight then rook e1 oh I'm
about to go pawn takes pawn check Bishop
e6 trying to block the file rook takes
b2 winning one pawn and I'm about to
visit on the b7 square Queen c7 going
back to defend it
Queen b1 what a beautiful little move
the Queen from a distance does all kind
of damage I'm doubly attacking the pawn
on b7 and my bishop and queen are also
attacking this pawn for later on so
rook b8 rook c1 and I have a huge threat
rook takes Knight why is that a huge
threat if you take with a pawn
bye-bye rook I have two guys on that if
you take with a queen Bishop b5 painting
and winning his block having fun in this
position I don't think so
he is he has to try but at the right
time because if you don't play Bishop
right now Bishop e7 doesn't work as I
take on c6 but if you try to do it
before like let's say in this position I
will take the b7 pawn if you did it in
this position I will just take the b7
pawn I will take the bishop on e7 you
will lose every name not good so he
tries pawn takes here Knight takes e5
and he plays the move Bishop to d6 again
I don't think this was the best move and
you will see how white punished it but
again just to show an example of how
much attack white already has let's take
a look at the variation if you would
have played this move then I take one
more time I took my one of the extra
pawns and I'm ready to take on b7 if you
try to say forget about the b7 pawn and
go here I'm just going to take it if you
take my knight I'm going to go Bishop
check what an attack on the King just a
terrible attack 97 Queen takes d5 is
that a beautiful move or not I think
it's a tremendous move if Bishop takes
Queen Bishop takes Knight on d7 is what
finally somebody said it I thought you
guys fell asleep on me yes if you take
my queen Bishop takes d7 is made game
over
so Wow alright we understand that black
already was in trouble but this move is
not going to save him now let's see if
you can think how white came about his
next move he says to himself okay so now
black is developing his pieces a he is
attacking my knight be even more
importantly he's about to castle so he
wants to combine both ideas he wants to
castle and he is also attacking my
knight what am I going to do and white
said well I think I have so many open
lines and diagonals and files
and attacking pieces that I can give my
night so I can a don't just lose it and
be forget about castling for black
forever watch what he did Knight takes
f7
what a brilliant sacrifice really a very
smart way to give up a piece normally I
frown when you just give pieces for no
reason but here time is even more
important than the material and getting
the King exposed the black King is
exposed gained over let's take a look
what happened after Knight takes well if
you don't take then good luck because
I'm attacking your rook in the corner
and I'm attacking your bishop here with
check you want to lose everything
be my guest so you could cancel and just
lose the bishop that doesn't look very
appealing so he decided to accept the
sacrifice
now why brings his queen with power
check and now black says okay maybe it's
time to give away a little material back
because if not I'm going to just fall
apart let's take a look at the ideas in
the game he went g6 if you would have
played for example King up then it's
going to be completely massacred so
let's say he hides then check here and I
can take I can play Bishop e7 or I can
play queen tech c8 either one of them
just wins the game I just win everything
back more blacking so in the game he
went g6 trying to save his King and
White said okay I can win material let
me do it because your King is still
going to be exposed BAM check after
takes takes so white managed to win a
rook and appoint for his Bishop of
course he sacrificed the night before
but again if you have to say what is the
most important thing like if you look
away from the board but then you've
never seen reform then look back at it
what is the most striking feature what
is the most thing that the first thing
to notice the most noticeable thing in
the board what is it yes the black King
on f7 is having a really bad hair day
right he is really in trouble he has no
pawns sheltering him the pieces are not
organized to defend him and the white
piece
are just all over it too many open files
and too many open diagonals that didn't
last long in the game we played Bishop
f5 ok any other move would not have
helped either I can tell you he's
already in trouble after here white
played rookie one another very nice
little move it says oh wow
the bishop is attacking the rook on b1
should I just move it should I do
something
answer no the King is just going to be
trout in deep trouble now I just want to
play Queen e8 check complete catastrophe
so he plays Bishop before that was the
idea Bishop f5 tried to block the file
and again White has a million good moves
I can go for example Queen f6 check and
take the bishop that's already nice but
white decides to be really flashy he
plays rook takes Bishop the last
defender goes bye-bye pawn takes check
now again you'll notice that any move is
going to lose if you go for example King
to e8 I'm going to go check if you block
with the bishop I'm going to take it
with mate if you go to the only other
legal Square mate very easy so he
decided to go the other way
now we go check again if you go to the
corner Bishop f6 is made so he had to
come out again Queen takes bishop check
how many of you think that the black
king is going to escape this massive
attack anybody think that black is going
to survive really don't put your money
on it sir no no no the Queen and the
bishop against the lone King bad news
King f7 Queen f6 check and now King e8
is just checkmate here so he goes this
way
Queen check notice that the queen is
playing on the light squares the bishop
on the dark squares King g7 Bishop f6
too much of an attack now again if King
h7 then is going to be mate I'm just
going to play let's see it check check
looks like maid
that's how the game ended by the way and
if instead he would have played King
eight six Bishop check King here check
King here check King here
Bishop check King here and now again
many moves f4 or h4 you could also play
the move h4 that's also made very very
quickly after King I don't even know
what to suggest it just totally over the
king is getting made it bad news so
again we saw two examples of taking the
initiative quickly not being afraid to
give a little bit of material at first
and once you have all your pieces active
in order to not allow the opponent to
run away and castle or organize the
defense or complete this development we
can give more material sometimes it will
be an exchange I look for a minor piece
something is going to be a minor piece
like a bishop and a knight and sometime
is going to be even a rook or your queen
it's all worth it if the final
destination of your opponent's king is
out of the board
checkmate